やあみんなドーゲンここにいるので
、日本での作業についての簡単な最新情報をお伝えしたいと思います
Q＆Aビデオ私は
日本の字幕を読む時間がなく
、ちょっと風変わりな楽しいビデオを作るという理由だけで、今英語でこれをやっています
えーと
、日本のビデオを公開したばかりなので、ご容赦ください。でも
、最新情報をお伝えしたいので、日本で働くこと
についてのQ＆Aビデオを録画
してみまし
た。
ビデオへのその場での回答は、それらの回答の多くが
ややそうだと認識される可能性がある
ということ
です。  LGBTコミュニティや外国人
に対する日本の差別についての質問
など、
できるだけ正直に答えようとしまし
たが、やはりデリケートなトピック
なので
、ビデオを作っているときに気づきました。 現在の職場で
トラブルが発生する可能性がある
ため、
そのままではリリースできません。これは、実際に
日本でのフルタイムの
仕事を辞めるという朗報です。 来月末になるので
、ビデオを再録画して、
4月にフルタイムでYouTubeを始められるようになってから、もう少し雄弁に表現して
みてください。そうですね、
これをフルにやります。  -これからの時間で、日本語でやろうと思っています。とにかくこれ
以上やめないでください。
また
、IIがまだ話せないことがもう1つありますが、
今月末までに公開されるはずです。
2月と私はそれについて別の発表をします
が、その
ようなことは
私が日本で働くことについてのQ＆Aをリリースしたくない理由の1つでもあります私は
そのビデオをリリースしたいと思いますそして私は正直になりたいです
可能な限りですが
、下にもう少し安全な足場ができるまで待ちたいです
私がそうするとき、ええ、何が起こって
いるのかを皆さんに知らせるための簡単なQ＆A更新ビデオ
すぐにまたあなたにさようなら